you're a grand old flannel advisor play
harder I got a I farted in here and it
smells like hell hey what is going on
YouTube oh it's coming up new year new
me oh you also check it out so you guys
know last year I work with the company
called east meets East so they hit me up
again this year and they told me that a
couple of you guys out there through our
collaboration made love angels together
found that connection
don't call me kill me but I'm saying huh
I got the body for it puppy in a diaper
with the arrow let me shoot love your
damn face no that's that's not what no
for those you who don't know East meets
East is the number one Asian dating app
for North America and Australia they
have like three hundred and fifty plus
thousand members using this and that's a
lot more than a hundred thousand that
was using it last year so if you guys
want to check it out go to the link in
the description box below and if you
find love through this don't be afraid
to tag me and hit me up I like hearing
the stories it gives me my booty tingles
why do I say [ __ ] like that but since
we're talking about dating let's go
ahead and get into the topic of this
video what you know people always ask
what is like the most important thing to
getting yourself out there to even date
somebody in the first place but before
anybody even gives you advice usually
people say some [ __ ] like nobody wants
to date me really nobody alright let me
just put this in perspective if I can
get somebody to date me trust me you can
my god some of you focus so much on your
negative qualities you don't give enough
love and space for your good qualities
to shine and most of the time it's like
perception and perspective some people
say some negative [ __ ] to me all the
time
oh my god David you're fat and light yo
that's just more cushion from when I
[ __ ] your mom and he saw me doing yoga
he said that my daily weird dog inspired
him to join yoga
so when you look at yourself in the
mirror and the first thing that you
think about is something negative and my
friend you're already messing up so
what's the first thing that you should
do when you get in to the dating game my
friends you really need to think about
this how can you expect other people to
appreciate you when you can't even do
that for yourself now I know you don't
want to hear this cliche advice because
you probably heard it a million times
before but just give me a chance and
listen to what I'm saying getting
yourself out there to date somebody
starts with self confidence I know I
know hold up yes you should probably
clean yourself up yes you should put
your best foot forward there are these
other factors but even before all that
mess this self-confidence [ __ ] is real
ask any girl who likes any dude - the
shallow [ __ ] that are looking for
money [ __ ] them my friends is always
gonna start here first
and by the way self-confidence doesn't
mean that every person that you come up
to is going to say yes it just helps
with the approach I gave this advice to
someone and they came back with - I'll
still get rejected boo yeah no [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's just cuz you're confident it
doesn't mean something your [ __ ]
magnet' you idiot they also have the
self-confidence to say no and I've said
this a million times before rejection is
something that you shouldn't be scared
of I have been rejected so many times
you can't even believe let me tell you
something ladies if I was single right
now [ __ ] you'd be rejected me right now
I scabbed over rejection to me is like
oil and water we just don't mix I hear
whatever the [ __ ] oh oh hey what's up
Elle so that's a maybe girl die so I can
see you in heaven my angel are you
definitely going to fall in love with
you
[ __ ] it just take my number uh that's
right I show them that what they don't
know what they need is something along
the line I got I got the [ __ ] number
listen I said this before if you don't
date you're cutting yourself short
that's just my opinion and then for me
by the way wasn't really a way for me to
just explore other people if anything it
was for me to explore myself and to
really find out what I want before I met
the woman that I'm with now I had this
concept the perception of what I thought
I wanted and that happened with the
first few girls that I dated it turned
out they were the exact opposite that
one it was just all in my head you just
have to be open and willing to have
type of experiences because you never
know what you're going to find out and
honestly that's like the exciting part
of dating this is where you get to
collect stories you get to tell you kids
amen
your daddy used to get a lot of
supermodel girls even though like it
really happened work on this first
expect rejections to happen stop looking
at yourself in comparison to other
people this person is cool that person's
handsome that person has so much cooler
and suave quality who the [ __ ] cares go
out there get rejected find love feel
that life experience go into your chest
cavity announcer nostrils straight up I
know you've seen some ugly ass obnoxious
losers and dweebs end up with people and
they get married and you're telling me
that you can't do it [ __ ] on out of here
you're subscribed to me which means you
already dope as [ __ ] so after this video
if you worked on yourself and you put
yourself out there to be available and
you got rejected and then you got some
dates let me know I want to know these
stories hey everybody I hope you guys
enjoyed that video if you do decide to
give dating a chance you guys already
know I don't [ __ ] with companies that I
don't like and remember a few people did
find love through this application and
through our collaboration which is why
east meets East and Dave Estelle decided
to do another collab oh wow so remember
to hit that link in the description box
below and if you get on that date
just remember to tag your boy David so
and say hey this guy or girl was
fan-fucking-tastic
thanks David so family sponsorships like
this are only happening because of your
love and support so as I said before
thank you thank you so much for being
there since day one that y'all bring
know what it is I love you very much
Happy Holidays Happy New Year give me a
hug and let me mouth kiss you Oh